Paul Vaughn who was arrested in front of
his many children joins us now he's
joined by his attorney Peter Breen who's
a senior counsel and VP at the Thomas
Moore Society thank you both very much
Paul first to you
um I I have to wonder
what did your children think of this
well Duggar they uh
you know there's a various thoughts and
processing going on as they're dealing
with this and trying to work through
what happened fortunately as a Christian
family we do a lot of studying about
historic Christianity and missionaries
in the past and persecution that has
happened in the church so they're
familiar with stories they know they're
people who've been martyred throughout
history they know they've been
persecuted and and picked on by bully
tyrants uh just in other parts of
History just like they are being in
America today
but you're not allowed to unleash the
FBI on an entire religion are you
absolutely not and and don't think
because they've been trained that makes
it okay
when when I when my kids go out to the
car to go to school and the FBI pulls up
armed running to the door and one of
them goes to the kids and holds the kids
with a long gun
the side of my driveway and does not let
them go into the house that is
absolutely as my wife said in the video
unacceptable
accountability well it's it's one of the
most shocking things I think I've ever
seen I I have to ask you so the FBI the
Department of Justice I can barely say
that phrase with a straight face is
claiming that you're a a violent
extremist who is a physical threat to
others do you Embrace violence have you
ever committed violence what are they
talking about
no I have no idea
there's absolutely no evidence of that
other the only place that has ever even
seen is in the documents that they made
up and uh used to justify in their mind
and through the
justice system the ones that signed off
on this needed some kind of
justification in their own minds to uh
to go after peaceful people that
disagreed with them politically Peter
Breen thank you for working on this case
for defending Paul Vaughn
um do you think that this is actually
going to go to trial
well Tucker when you've got a federal
prosecutor after you we always have to
plan for that you know Paul wasn't even
arrested by the local police for
trespassing uh and but those who did uh
who were arrested uh were leaning on the
tradition of Dr Martin Luther King he
himself was inspired by Mahatma Gandhi I
mean this is the great tradition of
American Civil Disobedience and it's not
the sort of thing that you turn into a
10-year felony Paul himself we believe
we have very strong defenses and hope to
hope to beat these charges at trial and
I hope you do so with the country that
rises up on your side because this is he
wasn't even arrested for trespassing at
the scene and over a year later they
send
the FBI to his house in front of his
children it's really just beyond I
appreciate both of you coming on tonight
thank you so much
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight